horses are emeriti Assam
they have feelings you know they
understand you and to be able to have
that special bond with the horse I think
it's very very special
my name's Andrew Lakeman and I'm a
racehorse trainer
I think we're a very young age I wanted
to be a jockey I was riding as an
apprentice in England and I got the
opportunity to come over to the United
States to work for a very famous trainer
in Maryland 1:40 in 2007 I was riding a
horse on the grass at Belmont Park and
my horse
clipped heels and I went down and had a
horrific accident which left me
paralyzed the doctor was very direct he
told me that I will never walk again
that feeling really hit me then thinking
I was never gonna ride again what am I
gonna do a chimera
when I was recovering I had in my mind I
couldn't give up I wanted to find my own
independence and I wanted to train
that's what I did I bought my own horse
I started out with him and I trained him
and I won with him working with the
horses
it's kind of like they know that I'm in
a wheelchair they kind of sense what's
going on they would ever hurt me getting
on the stall and I can check the leg you
know a lot of people would think that
they would jump away from the wheelchair
they would be afraid but no they were
like really understanding and caring you
know around me you know I'm good for a
lot of things but I think the most thing
I'm grateful for horses because they've
given me everything in my life and then
after the accident they continue to give
me a new life
you